I mean let me ask you about the death of
civilians so during the attack 1400
Israelis were
killed over 240 were taken hostage and
then in response as we sit
today uh Israel's military response has
killed over 10,000 people in Gaza and
given the nature of the demographics
it's it's a very heavily young
population over 40% of them are under
the age of 18 of those killed that's uh
of course according to Ministry of
Health of Palestinian
Authority so what do you think is the
long-term effect on the prospect of
Peace when so many civilians
die I mean I think it's disastrous
U uh I
mean the only way you're going to get
peace here uh is if you have a two-state
solution
um where the Palestinians have a
sovereign state of their own and there
is a sovereign Jewish State uh and these
two states live side by side American
Presidents since Jimmy Carter have
understood this full well and this is
why we have pushed very hard for
two-state solution indeed many American
Jews and many Israelis have pushed for a
two-state solution because they think
that that is the only way you're going
to get uh
peace uh between the two sides uh but
what's happened here is that in recent
years the Israelis have lost all
interest in a two-state solution uh and
it's in large part because the political
center of gravity and Israel has
steadily moved to the right uh when I
was a young boy uh the political center
of gravity in Israel was much further to
the left than it is today and uh it is
is in uh it is in a position now the
political center of gravity where
there's hardly any support for two-state
solution and Netanyahu and the rest of
the people in his government were in
favor or are in favor of a greater
Israel there's just no question about
that
well on top of that you now have had a
war where as you
described huge numbers of civilians have
been killed and you already had bad
blood between the Palestinians and the
Israelis before this
conflict uh and you can imagine how
people on each side now feel about
people on the other side so even if you
didn't have this opposition inside
Israel to a two-state
solution how could you possibly get the
Israelis now to agree to a two-state
solution U I think for the foreseeable
future the animosity inside Israel
towards the Palestinians is so great
that it is impossible to move the
Israelis in that direction and the
Israelis here are the key players more
so than the Palestinians because it's
the Israelis who control greater Israel
it's the Israelis who you have to
convince now I want to be clear here you
also ultimately have to get around the
fact that Hamas right is not committed
to a two-state solution but I think that
problem could be dealt with it's
important to understand that Arafat and
the PLO was once adamantly opposed to a
two-state solution but Arafat came
around to understand that that was
really the only hope for settling this
and he became a proponent of a two-state
solution and that's true of mmud a boss
who runs the PA in the West
Bank it's not true of hos at this point
in time they want a one-state solution
they want a Palestinian State and of
course the Israelis want a one-state
solution too which is a Jewish state
that controls all of um all of Greater
Israel so the question is can you get
some sort of agreement and I think to
get to your the nub of your question
given what's just happened uh it's
almost impossible to imagine that
happening anytime soon the cynical
perspective here is that uh those in
power benefit from conflict while the
people on both sides suffer is there
degree of Truth to that or for the
people in power to maintain power
conflict needs to continue no I I don't
believe that I mean just to take the
Netanyahu government or any Israeli
government that maintains uh the
occupation what you want is you want a
Palestinian population that submits to
Israeli domination of Greater Israel you
don't want resistance you don't want an
inada you don't want what happened on
October 7th in fact I think one of the
principal reasons that the Israelis are
pounding Gaza and killing huge numbers
of civilians punishing the civilian
population in ways that clearly violate
the laws of war is because they want the
Palestinians to understand that they are
not allowed to rise up and resist the
occupation that's their goal so I think
the Israelis would prefer that the
Palestinians roll over and accept
submission in terms of the people who
live in Gaza to include the elites and
the people who live in the West Bank to
include the elites they would much
prefer to move to some sort of situation
where uh the Palestinians have a state
of their own I think in the case of the
PA uh under abas they would accept a
two-state solution I think what at this
point in time Hamas wants is a one-state
solution but they want peace all of them
want peace um you know the two different
sets of leadership in Palestine and the
Israelis so you think Hamas wants peace
sure but on its own terms that's the
point what does peace look like for
Hamas at this point in time I think
peace basically means a greater Israel
controlled by Palestine are
Palestinians okay so essentially I mean
it's the whole land is called Palestine
and there's no Israel I think at this
point in time that's their principal
goal I do believe and there have been
hints over time Jimmy Carter has said
this that Hamas can be convinced that a
two-state solution assuming that the
Palestinians get a viable uh state of
their own that Hamas would buy into that
can we say that with a high degree of
certain certainty no but I think I think
the Israelis should have pursued that
possibility they should have worked with
the boss they should have worked with
Hamas to do everything they can to
facilitate a two-state solution because
I think ultimately that's in Israel's
interest now the Israeli government and
most Israelis at this point in time I
believe don't agree with that what do
you think of Israel starting the ground
invasion of Gaza recently on October
27th the question
is uh should they
continue uh until they have finally
defeated
Hamas uh there are all sorts of reports
in the media including in the Israeli
media that they're not going to be
allowed by the United States to continue
this
offensive uh for much more than a few
weeks um the Israeli have been saying it
would it's going to take in in the best
of all possible worlds a number of
months if not a year to finish off Hamas
well it doesn't look like they're going
to have enough time to do that I doubt
whether they can finish off Hamas even
if they're given the time uh I think
they're going to run into Fierce
resistance uh and when they run into
Fierce resistance and large numbers of
Israelis going to die start to die
uh they'll lose their appetite for this
and they the Israelis surely know at
this point in time that even if they
finish off Hamas even if I'm wrong and
they're able to finish off Hamas another
group is going to rise up to uh resist
the
occupation the idea that you can use
what Z Yaba insky called The Iron Wall
to beat the Palestinians into submission
is delusional it's just not going to
happen the Palestinians want a state of
their own they don't want to live under
occupation and uh there's no military
solution for Israel here there has to be
a political solution and the only viable
political solution is a two-state
solution I mean you can't go to
democracy you can't go to a situation
where you give the Palestinians equal
rights inside a greater Israel in large
part because there are now
as many Palestinians as there are
Israeli Jews and over time the balance
the demographic balance shifts against
the Israeli Jews and in favor of the
Palestinians in which case you'll end up
with a Palestinian state in Greater
Israel so you know democracy for all
doesn't work uh the Israelis I believe
for quite interested in ethnic cleansing
I think they saw this um uh
this recent set of events is an
opportunity to cleanse Gaza but that's
not going to happen uh the jordanians
and the Egyptians have made it clear
that that's not happening the United
States has now made it clear that that's
not happening and and the Palestinians
will not leave uh they'll die in place
uh so uh ethnic cleansing doesn't work
so you're really left with two
Alternatives a two-state solution or a
greater Israel that is a effectively an
apartheid state I mean that's what the
occupation has led to and all sorts of
people have been predicting this for a
long long time and you've now reached
the point you know here in the United
States if you say that Israel is an
apartheid state that's going to get you
into all sorts of trouble but the fact
is that Human Rights Watch Amnesty
International and Bellum which is the
leading Israeli Human Rights group all
three of those institutions or
organizations have issued detailed
reports making the case that Israel is
an apartheid state furthermore if you
read the Israeli media right all sorts
of Israelis including Israeli
leaders refer to Israel as an apartheid
state it's it's not that unusual to hear
that term used in Israel this is
disastrous for Israel in my opinion and
Steve Walt and I said this by the way
when we wrote the Israel Lobby that
Israel an aparte state which is
equivalent to Israel as an occupier uh
is not good for Israel uh and that
brings us back to the two-state solution
but as you and I were talking about a
few minutes ago it's hard to see how you
get a two-state
solution and the end result of this
conversation is utter
despair because the path to a two-state
solution is blocked by the amount of um
hate that's created by civilian deaths
so that plus the fact that the Israeli
government uh is filled with people uh
who have no interest in a two-state
solution they're
ideologically deeply committed to a
greater Israel they want all the land
between the Jordan River and the
Mediterranean Sea to
be part of a Jewish state they're just
ideologically committed to that and uh
and of course as we were talking about
before with regard to Hamas Hamas wants
everything between the river and the sea
to be a Palestinian State and you know
when you have two sides with those kinds
of views right um um you're in deep
trouble because there's little room for
compromise so what you have to do to get
this to work is you have to convince the
Israelis that it's in their interest to
have a two-state solution and and you
have you've already taken care of the PA
on this front the Palestinian Authority
but you've got to convince Hamas that
it's uh its maximalist goals are are not
going to work and it's in its interest
uh to follow in the footsteps of Arafat
and accept a two-state solution but uh
even if you do that at this point let's
say that you know there's a lot of
willingness uh intellectually on both
sides to do that the problem is that the
hatred that has been fueled by this
recent con uh this ongoing conflict is
so great that it's just hard to imagine
how you can make a two-state solution
work at this juncture uh that's why I've
sort of taken to saying and I hope I'm
wrong here that you know on the
two-state solution uh that that boat has
sailed it's just you know it's no longer
possible well again I believe in
leadership and there's other parties at
play here Other Nations Jordan so Saudi
Arabia other other players in the m in
the Middle East that could help that
could help through a normalization of
relationships and these kinds of things
there's there's always hope like you
said Slither of Hope Slither of hope I
think human civilization progresses
forward by taking advantage of the all
the slithers it can get uh let me ask
you about you mentioned the Israel Lobby
you wrote a book probably your most
controversial book on the topic not
probably clearly the most controversial
book I ever wrote so you've uh
criticized the Israel Lobby in the
United States for influencing US
policy um in the Middle East can you
explain what the Israel Lobby is their
influence and your
criticism over the past let's say a
couple
decades well the argument that Steve
Walt and I made actually we wrote an
article first and uh which appeared in
the London Review of Books uh and then
we wrote the book at
itself uh our argument is that the lobby
is a loose Coalition of uh individuals
and
organizations uh that push American
policy in a pro-israel
direction uh and uh basically the lobby
is interested in getting Israel excuse
me getting the United States and here
we're talking mainly about the American
government to support Israel no matter
what Israel does and our argument is
that if you look at the relationship
between the United States and Israel
it's unprecedented in modern history uh
this is the closest relationship that
you can find between any two countries
in recorded history it's truly amazing
the extent to which Israel and the
United States are joined at the Hep and
we support Israel no matter what almost
all the time uh and uh our argument is
that that is largely due to the
influence of the lobby the lobby is uh
an extremely powerful interest group now
it's very important to understand that
the American political system is set up
in ways that allow interest groups of
All Sorts to wield great influence
so in the United States you have an
interest group or a Lobby like the
National Rifle Association that makes it
well nigh impossible to get gun control
right uh and so with the Israel Lobby
you have this group of individuals and
organizations that wield enormous
influence on US policy toward the Middle
East and this
is not surprising given the nature of
the American political system uh so our
argument is that the lobby is not doing
anything that's illegal or illicit or
immoral or unethical it's just a good
old-fashioned American interest group
and it just happens to be extremely
powerful and our argument is that this
is not good for the United States
because
no two countries have the same interests
all the time and when our interests
conflict with Israel's interests we
should be able to do what we think is in
our national interest in America's
national interest but the lobby tends to
conflate America's national interests
with Israel's national interests and
wants the United States to support
Israel no matter what we also argue and
I cannot emphasize this enough given
what's going on in the world today that
the
Lobby's effects the lobby has not
been pushing policies that are in
Israel's interest so our argument is
that the lobby right the lobby pushes
policies that are not in America's
interest or not in Israel's interest now
you're saying to yourself what exactly
does he mean by
that what every president since Jimmy
Carter has tried to do as I said before
is to to a two-state solution to push
Israel which is the dominant
player in Greater Israel push Israel to
accept the two-state solution and we
have run into huge resistance from the
lobby whenever we tried to let's be
blunt about it co Israel right in a
perfect world where there was no Lobby
and an American president was free to
put pressure on Israel to cores Israel I
believe we would have gone a long way
towards getting two-state solution and I
believe this would have been an Israel's
interest uh but we couldn't get a
two-state solution because it was almost
impossible to put meaningful pressure on
Israel because of the lobby so this was
not in Israel's interest and it was not
in America's interest and that was the
argument that we made and uh we of
course got huge push back for making
that argument what's the underlying
motivation of the lobby is it religious
in nature is it um similar to the way
warhawks are sort of militaristic in
nature is it nationalistic in nature
what what's uh if you were to describe
this loose Coalition of people what what
would you say is their motivation well
first of all I think you have to
distinguish between Jews and Christians
you want to remember that there are a
huge number of Christian zionists who
are deeply committed to Israel no matter
what
right and then there are a large number
of Jews the Jews are obviously the most
important of those two groups in the
Israel lobby but you know one of the
arguments that we made in the book is
that you should not call it the Jewish
Lobby because it's not populated just by
Jews and Christian zionists are an
important part of that lobby but
furthermore there are a good number of
Jews who are opposed to the lobby uh and
the policies that the lobby perve and
there are uh a number of Jews who are
prominent
anti-zionists right so and they're
obviously not in the lobby or or if you
take a group like Jewish voice for peace
right Jewish voice for peace is not in
the lobby so it's wrong to call it a
Jewish lobby but with regard to the
American Jews who were in that Lobby uh
I I think that really this is all about
nationalism it's not so much religion
many of those Jews who are influential
in the lobby are not religious in any
meaningful sense of that term but they
self-identify as Jewish in in in the
sense that they feel they're part of a
Jewish nation and that in addition to
being an American right they are part of
this tribe this nation called Jews and
that they have a
responsibility um to push the United
States in ways that support uh the
Jewish state so I I think that's what
drives most if not almost all the Jews
this is not to say there's not a
religious dimension for some of them but
I think that the the main connection is
much more tribal in nature so I had a
conversation with Benjamin nahu and he
said fundamentally if you're
anti-zionist you're
anti-Semitic so the the the Zionist
project is tied at the hip to the Jewish
project what do you have to say to that
look you can Define
anti-Semitism any way you want right and
you can Define anti-Semitism to
incorporate anti-zionism
uh and uh I think we have reached the
point where
anti-Semitism is identified today not
just with anti-zionism but with
criticism of Israel if you criticize
Israel people will say some people will
say you're an
anti-semite and if that's your
definition of
anti-semitism it's taken an important
term and stretched it to the point where
it's
meaningless right so when steveen I wrot
wrote the book uh wrote the article and
then wrote the book all sorts of people
said that we were anti-semites this is a
ludicrous charge but what they meant was
you're criticizing the lobby you're
criticizing Israel and therefore you're
an
anti-semite okay if that's what an
anti-semite is somebody who criticizes
Israel you know probably half the Jewish
Community if not more in the United
States is anti-Semitic and of course you
get into all these crazy games where
people are calling Jews self-hating Jews
and anti-semites because they're
critical of Israel but even people who
are anti-zionist I don't think they're
anti-semitic at all uh you can argue
they're misguided that's fine but uh
many of these people are Jewish and
proud of the fact that they're Jewish
they just don't believe that nationalism
and Jewish nationalism is a force that
should be applauded and you you want to
understand that in the American context
there is a rich tradition of
anti-zionism
right and these were not people who were
anti-semites if you go back to the 30s
40s 50s and the same thing was even true
in Europe there were all sorts of
European Jews who were opposed to
Zionism were they anti-semites I don't
think so but we've gotten to the point
now where people are so interested in
stopping any criticism of Israel that
they wield this weapon of uh calling
people anti-semites uh so uh Loosely
that uh the term has kind of lost
meaning so I I think Netanyahu is is
wrongheaded to equate uh anti-zionism
with anti-Semitism Alan dtz was one of
the people that called you specifically
anti-semitic U so
just looking at the space of
discourse how do
you where's this Slither of Hope for
healthy discourse about us relationships
with
Israel
um between you and alen dershwitz and
others like him well I think until there
is a settlement of the Israeli
Palestinian conflict there's no hope of
putting an end to this nonsense right so
these are just uses of terms to kind
of cheat your way through the through
the discourse it's shortcut no it's the
silence people right it's very very
important to understand that one of the
Lobby's principal goals is to make sure
we don't have an open discourse a
freewheeling discourse about Israel
because they understand people in the
lobby understand that if you have an
open discourse Israel will end up
looking very bad right you don't want to
talk about the occupation you don't want
want to talk about how Israel was
created right all all these subjects are
ones that uh will cause problems for
Israel see just to go to the present
crisis okay when you have a
disaster and what happened on October
7th is a disaster one of the first
things that happens is that people begin
to ask the question how did this happen
right what's the root cause of this
problem this is a disaster we have to
understand what caused it so that we can
work to uh to make sure it doesn't
happen again so we can work to shut it
down and then make sure it doesn't
happen again but once you start talking
about the root causes right you end up
talking about how is real was created
right and that means telling a story
that is not pretty about how the
zionists conquered
Palestine uh and number two it means
talking about the occupation right it's
not like uh Hamas attacked on October
7th because there were just a bunch of
anti-semites who hated Jews and wanted
to kill Jews this is not you know Nazi
Germany right this is directly related
to the occupation and to what was going
on inside of Gaza and it's not in
Israel's interest or the Lobby's
interest to have an open discourse about
what the Israelis have been doing to the
Palestinians since I would say roughly
1903 when the second Aliah came to
Israel or came to what was then
Palestine right we want to talk about
that and we don't want to talk about
from the Lobby's point of view the
influence that the lobby has right uh
it's better from the Lobby's point of
view if most Americans think that uh
American support of Israel is just done
for all the right moral and strategic
reasons not because of the lobby and
when John mirer and Steve Walt come
along and say you have to understand
that this special relationship is due in
large part to the Lobby's influence that
is not an argument that uh people in the
lobby want to hear so the point is you
have to go to Great Lengths for all
these reasons you have to go to Great
Lengths to silence people like me and
Steve Walt and one of the ways to do
that is to call us anti-semites I think
the chapter or the section of the book
where we talk about this charge of
anti-Semitism is called the Great
silencer that's what we call the charge
of anti-Semitism the great silencer who
wants to be called an anti-semite
especially in the wake of the Holocaust
do I want to be called an anti-semite oh
my God no uh and uh so it's very
effective effective but you know it is
important to talk about these issues in
my humble opinion and I think if we had
talked about these issues uh way back
when it would have gone a long way
towards uh you know maybe getting a
two-state solution which I think was the
best alternative here it it's
complicated and I wonder if you can
comment on the complexity of this
because criticizing ing Israel and you
know criticizing the
lobby can
um for a lot of people be a dog whistle
for sort of anti-Semitic conspiracy
theories that you know this idea that
Jews run everything run the world or
this kind of
cabal and you know
it's it's also very true that people who
are legitimately anti-Semitic
are also critics of Israel in the same
kind of way and so it's such a
complicated landscape in which to have
discussions because
um uh you know even people like David
Duke uh who are you know racists don't
sound racist on the
surface well I haven't listened to him
enough but like you know there's dog
whistles it's it's a complicated space
in which to have
discussions because it uh I mean I
wonder if you can sort of speak to
that um because there's this silencing
effect of calling everybody anti-semitic
but it's also true that there is
anti-Semitism in the world like there is
a sizable population of people that hate
Jews there's probably a sizable
population of people who hate Muslims
too but you know I lot of hate out there
a lot of hate out there uh but the
hatred of Jews has has like a long
history and so you have like you know
Rolling Stones have a a set of great
hits and there's just a set of great
hits of the ways conspiracy theories
that you can make up about the Jews that
are used as part of the hatred uh so
there's like nice templates for that and
I I just wonder if you can comment
on operating as a historian as an
analyst as a strategic thinker in this
kind of space yeah we obviously when we
wrote the article which we did before
the book gave the subject a great deal
of thought I mean uh what you say just
now is music to our ears I'm talking for
me and about me and Steve uh I mean I
think that you know your point about dog
whistles is
correct look we went to Great Lengths to
make it clear that this is not a cabal
it's not a conspiracy and in fact in a
very important way thew Lobby operates
out in the open right
uh they brag about their power right and
this was true before we wrote the
article right and um and we said in the
article and the book and you heard me
say it here first of all it's not a
Jewish Lobby
right um secondly it's not a cabal right
it's an American interest group and and
the American system is designed such
that interest groups are perfectly legal
and some of them are super effective EXA
I mean you hit the nail right on the
head that's exactly right
and you know and there was nothing that
we said that was
anti-semitic by any reasonable
definition of that term and you know
huge numbers of Jews have known me and
Steve over the years and nobody ever
ever said that we were anti-semitic
before March 2006 when the article
appeared because we're not
anti-semitic but look you've got this
interest group right that has a
significant influence on American
policy and on Israeli
policy
and you want to talk about it it's just
important to talk about it it's
important for Jews right in the United
States for Jews in Israel to talk about
this the idea that you want to silence
critics is not a smart way to go about
doing business in my
opinion if we were wrong if Steve and I
were so wrong and our arguments were so
foul they could have easily exposed
those arguments they could have gone uh
into combat with this in terms of the
Marketplace of ideas and easily knocked
us down the problem was that our
arguments were quite powerful and
instead of engaging us and defeating our
arguments they wanted to silence us and
this is not good right it's not good for
Israel it's not good for the United
States and I would argue in the end if
anything it's going to Foster
anti-Semitism I think you don't want to
run around telling people that they
can't talk about about Israel without
being called an anti-semite it's just
not it's not healthy uh in terms of the
issue that you're raising right but I
still agree with you that it is a tricky
issue it's I I don't want to make light
of that you know I know that there's
this piece of literature out there
called the protocols of the Elders of
Zion and I fully understand that if
you're not careful you can come close to
writing volume two of the protocol but I
don't believe that we wrote anything
that was even close to that and again I
think that a healthy debate on the
issues that we were raising would have
been in not only in America's interest
but it would have been in Israel's
interest yeah I mean um Underneath It
All is just I wonder why there's so much
hate against groups why it's such a
sticky way of thinking
not just tribalism like proud of your
country and kind of hating another
country but really deeply hating like
hating in a way where it's part of your
identity kind of
hate well just to make a general point
on this issue in our conversation here
today you often talk about individual
leaders and the word individual often
pops up in your vocabulary yes I believe
that we are ultimately social animals
before we are individuals I believe
we're born into tribes we're heavily
socialized and that we carve out space
for our
individualism but we are part of tribes
and or social groups or nations call
them what you want ethnic groups
religious groups but the fact is that
these tribes often crash into each other
and when they crash into each other uh
they end up hating each other
uh if you go to a place like Bosnia
right the croats and the serbs oh my God
and then throw in the
bosniacs which is the term for Bosnian
Muslims and you know Muslims croats
serbs uh oh and uh the tribes you know
hate each other uh and uh in a funny way
that hatred almost never goes away uh
and uh I I guess there are some
exceptions to that uh if you look at the
Germans after World War II they've gone
a long way towards reducing I wouldn't
want to say completely eliminating but
reducing a lot of the hatred uh that
existed between Germans and their
neighbors uh but that's really kind of
an anomalous case uh I mean you go
around East Asia today and the hatred of
Japan in a place like China the hatred
of Japan in a place like Korea just not
to be
underestimated and uh so but I think a
lot of it just has to do with the fact
that you're dealing with social groups
that have crashed into each other uh at
one point or another and there are those
lingering effects and by the way this
gets back to our discussion a few
minutes ago about trying to get a
two-state solution between the
Palestinians and the Israeli Jews now
that you have had uh this horrible War
uh which is
ongoing it's
interesting to ask to go back to World
War II now you said uh you studied Nazi
Germany in in the 30s from a perspective
of
maybe offensive
realism uh but just to look at the
Holocaust it's sometimes popular in
public discourse today to compare
certain things to the Holocaust people
have compared the Hamas attack on Israel
to the Holocaust saying things like it's
the the
biggest attack on Jews since the
Holocaust which kind
of
implies that there's a
comparison people have made that same
comparison in the other
direction what do you make of this
comparison is it comparable is it is the
use of the
Holocaust uh have any accuracy in
comparisons of modern modern day
international
politics is it possible that you could
have another
genocide yes and I would argue that what
you had in Rwanda was a
genocide right the Holocaust is not the
only
genocide I believe the word genocide is
used too Loosely
today uh and as you know lots of people
and I mean lots of people who are propel
Palestinian accused the Israelis of
engaging in genocide in Gaza I think
what the Israelis are doing in Gaza uh
represents a massacre I I would use that
term given the number of civilians that
they've killed and the fact that they've
been indiscriminate in terms of how
they've been bombing Gaza but I would
not use the word
genocide uh for me a genocide is where
one side attempts to eliminate another
group from the planet uh I think that
what happened with the Holocaust was
clearly a genocide and that the Germans
were bent uh on destroying all of
European jeury and if they could have
gotten their hands on uh Jews outside of
Europe they would have murdered them as
well that's a genocide and I think with
the hutus and the tootsies you had a
similar situation uh I think with the
Turks and the Armenians during World War
I that was a genocide but I have a
rather narrow definition of what a
genocide is and I don't think there are
many cases that qualify as a genocide
the Holocaust certainly does okay
now what Hamas did doesn't even come
close to what happened to European jury
between let's say
1939 uh and 1945 although I date the
start of the Holocaust to
1941 if we were you know looking at it
closely but let's just say 1939 when
they invade Poland 1939 to
whated pales in comparison it's hard to
believe anybody would make that argument
right yes a lot of Jews died uh but uh
uh
hardly
uh hardly any compared to the number
that died uh you know at the hands of
the Germans I mean it just no parallel
at all uh and furthermore Hamas was in
no position to kill all the Jews in the
Middle East just not not going to happen
and but there's also levels of things
you know using uh Germans using uh human
skin for lamps there's just levels of
evil in this world yes but you don't see
that with I mean that's not what Hamas
is doing I mean I I I want to be very
clear here I am not justifying the kill
hamas's killing of civilians okay not
for one second but I'm just saying and
and and by the way just to go to the
Israelis and what they're doing in Gaza
right as I said to you before I do
believe that is a massacre and I believe
that's to be condemned the killing of
civilians uh this is not legitimate
collateral damage they're directly
punishing the PO population but I would
not call that a genocide right and I
would not compare that to the Holocaust
for for one second I just want to be
very clear on that do you think uh if
Israel could they would avoid the death
of any
civilians so you're saying there's some
degree of punishment of collective
they're purposely killing civilians it's
this is the Iron Wall they're trying to
beat the Palestinians in the
submission right there's no way you kill
this many
civilians
um if you're trying to precisely take
out Hamas Fighters and by the way the
Israeli spokesman the IDF spokesman has
explicitly said that we are not pursuing
Precision bombing and that what we are
doing is trying to you know maximize the
amount of Destruction and damage uh that
we can inflict on the Palestinians and
uh I I I think this is a major mistake
on the part of Israel first of all it
ends up being a moral stain on your
reputation number one and number two it
doesn't work it doesn't work the the
Palestinians are not going to roll over
and submit to uh Israeli domination of
their life um so you know the whole
concept of the Iron Wall uh gabatin
Sky's term ter was
misguided um and and and by the way the
iron if you look at what the Israelis
are doing they're trying to do two
things one is the iron wall and that's
where you punish the civilian population
in Gaza and get them to submit the other
thing that they're trying to do is get
Hamas they want to destroy Hamas and the
belief there is that if they destroy
Hamas they've solved the problem but as
many Israelis know including people on
the hard right even if you destroy Hamas
they are going to to be replaced by
another group another resistance group
uh and that resistance group will employ
Terror yeah I think you I think you've
said that uh other terrorist
organizations have used the situation in
Palestine as a as a kind of a recruit
recruitment
mechanism for for a long time Osama bin
lad made it clear that this was one of
those principal reasons for attacking
the United States right and the United
States attacked back and uh got us into
a 20-year war that
cost the lives of millions of people not
not American but uh human beings yeah
and uh engaged in torture in
torture yeah no I think if you look at
how we reacted to
9/11 and how the Israelis are reacting
to what happened on October 7th uh
there's uh quite a bit of similarity in
that both sides the Israeli side and the
American side uh are enraged right and
they lash out and they go on a
rampage and the end result is not good
is there capacity within Israel or with
within United States after
911 to do something approximating turn
the other
cheek
of understanding the root of Terror is
hate and fighting that hate
with uh not the sound naive but
compassion well I I don't think in
either case you're going to turn the
other cheek uh I think well some I what
I mean by that is some limited powerful
military response but very limited Yeah
couple with a smart political strategy
political strategy diplomacy yeah that's
what they should have done yeah right
but is there capacity for that or from
your offensive realism perspective it's
just the odds are really
low no for my offensive realist
perspective or my realist perspective
that's what you should do right okay my
my view is states are rational actors
they should be cunning right they should
think about uh the Strategic situation
they're in and choose the appropriate
response and uh what happens and this is
why my theory is not always correct is
that sometimes states are not rational
and they
misbehave I would argue in the Israeli
case uh that it would have been good
after October 7th or starting on October
7th if the United States had uh tried to
hold the Israelis back and countenance
uh a more uh moderate response a more uh
to to SP take some time just to think
about how to deal with this problem
instead of lashing out I I think given
what happened to the Israelis given how
shocked they were given the level of
fear given the level of Rage they were
going to lash out and I don't believe
that was in their interest I think it
would have been made it would have made
sense to to think about it and uh to
think about a smarter strategy than
they're now employing and I think you
know the Americans blew it the Americans
gave him a be hug and a green light and
said we'll give you all the Weaponry you
need and go out and do it and uh I don't
think that was the smart thing to do
look in the wake of October 7th the
Israelis had no good strategy right it's
it's not like there's a magic formula
that they just didn't see and we should
have told them what the magic formula
was right that's not true they were in a
sense caught between IR rock and a hard
place in terms of what to do but they're
smarter things and Dumber things and I
think the
Israelis lashed out in ways that are
counterproductive I think you know going
on a rampage and you know killing huge
numbers of civilians is not it's
obviously morally wrong but it's also
just not in their strategic interest
right I mean uh cuz it's it's not going
to buy them anything right and in fact
it's going to cost them right because
people all over the planet are turning
against Israel uh I saw you know an
Israeli think tank today uh that has
been tracking uh protest around the
world um gave some figures for what it
looked like like uh between October 7th
and October 13th in terms of the number
of uh protests around the world that
were pro-israel versus Pro Palestine and
then it looked at the numbers from U
October 13th up to the present and I
think the numbers were 69% were Pro
Palestinian in the first six days after
October 7th
69% and I think 31% take these numbers
with a grain of salt 31% were pro-israel
so I think it was 69 and
31 um and uh since then since October 13
if you look at the number of protests
around the world 95% have been Pro
Palestinian and 5% have been
pro-israel uh and what this tells you is
that public opinion around the world has
shifted against Israel and if you look
at some of the demonstrations in places
like London and Washington DC it's truly
amazing the number of people who are
coming out in support of the
Palestinians and uh all of this again is
just to support my point that it was
just not smart for Israel to uh launch
this bombing campaign right you can make
an argument for going after Hamas and
doing it in a surgical way or as
surgical a way as possible uh but uh
that's not what they did did and again
my point to you is I think that this
punishment campaign is not going to work
strategically in other words they're not
going to beat the Palestinians into
submission they're not going to finish
off Hamas and at the same time by
pursuing this strategy they're doing
huge damage to their reputation around
the world well I just uh yeah in the
wake of October
7th given the geopolitical context
I think there's a lot of Leverage to be
the great ethical
superpower that demonstrate power
without killing any
civilians and use that leverage
diplomatic leverage to push forward
something like abrahamic Accords with
more nations with with Saudi Arabia push
for peace
aggressively peace agreements this kind
of stuff economic relationships all this
kind of stuff and thereby pressure the
Palestinian
Authority you know towards
um perhaps a two-state
solution but I think what you're missing
here just in the Israeli case is that
the Israeli government is not interested
in the two-state solution and you want
to remember that Benjamin Netanyahu who
looks very hawkish when you look at him
in
isolation doesn't look so hawkish when
you look at him compared to the rest of
the people in his
cabinet right he he he almost looks like
a moderate he's got a lot of people who
are way out to the right of him
and these people and this of course
includes Netanyahu are not interested in
the two-state solution so the question
you have to ask yourself is you if
you're if you're Benjamin Netanyahu and
it's July 7th late in the excuse me
October 7th late in the day what do you
do you're not thinking about it to State
solution you're thinking about an
occupation that's not going to end and
the question is how do you deal with the
Palestinians given what's just happened
well there's people in the cabinet and
then there's history and history
remembers great leaders and so uh
Benjamin nyaho can look in the streets
of Israel and see the protests and think
of how history will remember him and I
think a two-state solution is on the
table for a great leader well it was
there was he the person who was g to
take advantage of it I don't think so
but well he's a student of History well
at this point what the will see does I
mean it's very at this point it's very
difficult um like you said 95% now or
whatever the number is of protests I
think the the window in which Israel has
the ears of the world they can do the
the big ethical peace act action towards
peace is uh I think has closed or maybe
there's still a slowther but it's just
um uh the slippery slope of of hate is
has taken off it's quite depressing to
watch what's going I I agree 100%
unequivocally
depressing